uh we're going to be talking about how
to build the oh the top five techniques
to build the worst micro server system
ever
I really like this image as a
representation of microservices because
you've got this this gentleman on a
scooter it's a bit washed out on the
projector but he's going really fast and
he's not he's not hampered by any bloat
like protective headgear or anything and
the center of gravity is really high and
the pivot point is really low and all it
takes is one bump in the ground and
permanent brain damage
just like microservices
so who am I and why am I qualified to
talk to you about microservices
my name is William brander I'm from
South Africa and I know these South
African accent can be a little bit
difficult to understand at times so I
will try and enunciate a little bit
clearer than I usually do and I will try
to speak a little bit slower than I
usually do hopefully that helps
and see for the mug I am the world's
okayest programmer
I'm also incredibly passionate about
building bad systems
I hope some of that passion is going to
come through and energize the room so
that we can end the day on a high note
there are three things that I dislike
about this mug the first is that the a
in program is tilted ever so slightly to
the side just enough to bother my OCD
the second is that the font is
dangerously close to Comic Sans without
actually being Comic Sans because that
would be sort of cool in an ironic way
but this isn't it's just like a weird
knockoff
and then the third is that the mug is
unfortunately unverified it it may
surprise you to learn that there was not
in fact a worldwide census done on
developerability with me Landing Square
in the middle
so I went about looking to see if
there's a there's other ways that I
could prove that I was an okay
programmer and I spent some time looking
through my company slack and my
co-workers definitely don't think I'm
the best programmer either
but at least one of them doesn't think
I'm the worst so I've got that going for
me
but what does being an okay programmer
have to do with writing bad systems
right being an okay programmer means
that I've probably written some systems
that I'm proud of and some that I'm a
little bit ashamed of but I'm sure
everyone has written some bad systems
does it has anyone not written a bad
system before if anyone's hiring look
around for hands now
we've all worked in some bad systems so
what do I bring to the table that that
can Elevate me and I can really make it
that I'm the guy to teach you how to
write bad systems
well that's got to do with who I work
for I work for a company called
particular software we make in-service
bus has anybody heard of particular
well we've got a booth outside so if you
haven't heard of us we've done a really
bad job
anybody heard of end service but I hope
everyone anybody using in service pass
my salary
so for those of you who don't know and
service bus is a library and framework
for building distributed systems so
whether you want to build microservices
or so or just partition your system and
service bus can help you do that
but that's not what this talk is about
so what does working for particular have
to do with making bad systems
well at particular if you work on the
engineering team you also do support
There's no distinction between
engineering and support which means that
if you work on end service bus you
support in-service bus and you support
the customers that use ad Service Plus
and that's honestly one of the more fun
things that I get to do is is support
because I get to see a lot of different
systems applied in a lot of different
ways at a lot of different scales and I
get to see how people are using and
service bus to build these distributed
systems
but here's the thing about support
if one was were to assume that system
quality follows a normal distribution
where you've got some really poor
quality systems on the one side and a
few really high quality systems on the
other side with most systems having
reasonable quality sort of in the middle
that doesn't really help with support
because the people that have got the
high quality systems aren't coming to
support for help and the people that
have got the medium Quality Systems
aren't coming either because they can
probably work out their problems
themselves
so the types of systems that I see when
I do support are the ones down here
and I see a lot of these
in fact as far as I'm concerned based on
my history with support it means that
the distribution of system quality does
not follow a normal distribution like
this as far as I'm concerned all systems
are bad and as an industry we should be
ashamed of ourselves for what we do into
our Pro customers
to microservices right why do we do
microservices
the Consulting answer for why we do
microservices is we want to decrease
coupling so we can have independent
deployability we can scale things up and
down without bothering the rest of the
system and blah blah blah blah nobody
does microservices for that we do
microservices so that we can increase
complexity and decrease performance
we do microservices so that we can come
up with the most convoluted way to
render angle brackets for a browser
and most importantly we do microservices
because we don't want to be seen to be
doing a monolith right monoliths are bad
if you if you start a project and say
well I'm going to start to the model of
architecture
uh you get you get looks of Despair from
your colleagues every new project is
it's going to be a microservice
architecture right
monoliths aren't bad though they're good
this picture on the the left-hand side
left hand side is of the kailash temple
in India
it's carved from a single Rock making
this the largest man-made monolith in
the world the Erp system you've been
working on for the last seven years
doesn't come close
he has a different picture of it with a
slightly better angle you can see
there's people on the probably in the
way there there's people on the side on
the left to give you an idea of the
scale of this
this is huge this is a massive
undertaking they carved this from hand
well I mean not from hand they didn't
claw the rock where they had tools but
they weren't electrical pneumatic tools
this must have taken an immense amount
of planning dedication work effort this
is this has been a labor of love for
someone and a whole bunch of slaves
probably
but it's beautiful
monoliths can be beautiful don't don't
think you have to do microservices
because the alternative is model if it's
there's a there's a spectrum and a whole
lot of options in between
as a side note could you imagine what
this would have looked like if they
built this using scrum
the talk I'm going to assume that we
have a system and we're now trying to
transition the system into microservices
and make it as bad as possible and we're
going to see a few techniques that we
can do with that
so we've got a monolith it's a monolith
so it must be bad so it's a tire fire
over monolith
and we're going to transition this to
microservices and a typical technique
and it's come up a few times at the
conference already is to apply with
something known as the Strangler fig
pattern where you take a bit of
functionality in your system say the
charge credit card method you isolate
that from the rest of your code and then
you move that off to a service and then
your main monolith can call the the new
service instead of having to have that
call in process
yay we've micro serviced
what have we actually done though to our
system so if we apply this everywhere
what is the result
well let's take a look at the throughput
of the system and how the throughput
changes as the load on the system
changes
we'll start at the monolith so as the as
the load of the monolith increases the
throughput will increase as well at the
start it'll increase fairly linearly and
by that I don't mean one to one but
there will be some like K Factor where
as the load increases by one that the
throughput will increase by Point
somewhere between zero and one hopefully
not zero
and as you as the load increases even
more that throughput should increase a
little more as well but the rate of
change of increase will decrease a
little bit because the as the system is
doing more things concurrently there's
more handing over to different threads
there's more exchanges you're waiting
for resources
so it will start to taper off a bit
and eventually it's going to get to a
point where the throughput is going to
drop off completely
and you might ask yourself well why what
is the behavior that's causing this to
happen
and this has got to do with the way
that.net does memory management so
in.net there's three types of garbage
collection events generation zero
generation one and generation two
technically there's also generation
three or large object Heap but for the
purposes of this discussion we can fold
that into generation two
and the way that garbage collection
works is that when you're trying to
allocate a memory in.net if there's
certain criteria met.net goes and says
okay I need to free up some memory let
me go and do a gen zero garbage
collection event
and a gen zero garbage collection event
is intended to clear up resources that
have been allocated and freed fairly
quickly so VAR X is a function VAR x
equals ABC and then the function
finishes the garbage collector can
retrieve that memory and return it back
to the pool
but if the garbage collector tries to
retrieve or tries to free up a bit of
memory in gen 0 and it can't it promotes
that to generation one so generation one
is intended to be for longer lived
variables a longer lived memory perhaps
it's a it's a it's a variable on a class
and the class sits around for a bit
longer and does a few other things
if a generation one gobs collection
event runs and it can't clear up memory
because something still reference in
that object it promotes it to generation
two
and that's where the problem happens
so generation 2 in.net is a stop the
world event where as a generation 2
garbage collection event starts all user
threads are paused in your app domain
which means only the or except for the
thread doing the garbage collection so
all of your your other threads will
pause and many years ago stack Overflow
experienced this and Mark grave I wrote
a blog post explaining why this happened
and what they were trying to do to work
around it these three big spikes over
here are increases in response time
because the Gen 2 garbage collection
event was pausing all user threads in
the application
so the performance at these points was
very very poor
it's gotten a lot better since then
after this came out we got the
concurrent garbage collection
configuration and now that's been
replaced with the background garbage
collection configuration
which doesn't
uh
at interleave some of the garbage
collection for Gen 2 and it more
proactively gets uh gen 1 and gen zero
garbage collection done so Gen 2 garbage
collection now pauses and then resumes a
little bit and then the garbage
collection carries on in a different
thread a little bit later so the pause
in this sort of split out it's still a
horrible experience when you're dealing
with performance
the service it does load
as the load increases the throughput
will increase the throughput will also
increase at a fairly linear rate but it
will increase lower than the monolith
because you've introduced a network hop
network operations are expensive
which means that these threads that are
doing the the processing are probably
going to hang around a little bit longer
so there's going to be more contention
for resources which means that
flattening off is going to come sooner
and because they're hanging around even
longer there's more chance that they're
going to be promoted to generation 2
which means that drop-off is going to
come even sooner
so by simply Distributing our system we
could have potentially made the overall
throughput of the system worse the first
rule of distributed computing is don't
distribute your computing
but we've gone ahead and done this and
we've potentially made our the
throughput of our system worse this
isn't always true for instance if the
charge credit card method was on the hot
path and we isolated this and moved this
off we could then scale that Hardware up
independently but we're not going to do
that we're just going to microservice
the way we learned at the conference so
we're going to do everything on one
machine anyway
so the first Technique we can use to
mess your systems up is to put an HTTP
call in front of everything
who you are remembers when dotnet 3 came
out with WCF right there there were
those people going around everything
should be a WCF class operation contract
at all
it's a great idea
that was a that was a very weird time
there was what wcfwpf
wouldn't work for a foundation in Cloud
spaces and quad spaces just sort of
disappeared very quickly on in the in
the evolution of net there
Okay so we've taken our monolith and
we've strangled a figged it until it's
no longer monolith and now it's
distributed we still have the same
coupling between the components we still
have all the same problems we had before
we've now just made the performance
lower
so it's still a monolith that's just
distributed
um and it that means instead of a
problem that we have with our monolith
we're working with our models we've now
got to also introduce Network topology
coupling to that so that's another layer
of coupling that we've put in there
so it's not just the tire fire it's a
burning field of tires
this is a good first step
um
but this is difficult for us to work on
this isn't a pleasant experience and we
don't want to make our lives worse we
just want to make the system worse right
we want to enjoy our job
so we go to business and we say
um I bet you I can rewrite the system in
six months
did anybody find themselves thinking
that I've done it many times at that
particular I've even tried a few times
you failed miserably
the thing with big bang rewrites is that
they don't work
little asterisks in the air they work in
two specific scenarios which I'll get to
later
but why don't they work why do big bang
rewrites of large complex systems fail
and that's got to do with how software
works for these large systems so as
you're developing the system we'll have
another graph here we're on the y-axis
we've got the functionality that's
available in the system the amount of
features that we've got and on the
x-axis we've got the time that we spent
developing the system and at the start
of the system as you start developing
it's fairly easy to add new
functionality because you don't have
competing components with each other
you're still getting to know all the
business rules that you have to work
through you know it's a nice time to
work this is the green fields area we
all love greenfields projects right
as we carry on working though the rate
at which we can add new features
decreases because we have to add
features where we didn't really design
the architecture to match that feature
set at the beginning so it's a little
bit slower to add the features we have
to change a few things and propagate and
there's competing business rules that we
have to worry about
but that's fine and then eventually it
gets to a point where adding any better
functionality takes a lot of time and
effort
potentially even just changing the name
of a field on a form could be a full
Sprint process to do sometimes
so let's assume that at this point here
this is where we went to business after
we've done our distributed monitors and
we said please can we have six months to
do a rewrite after we've done the
rewrite everything will be wonderful the
UI will be modern it'll the performance
will be better and we'll be able to add
features before you even know what to
ask for it'll be so good
and businesses well okay six months
I'll give you six months to do this and
you're ecstatic because now you get to
do new work again that's great
so now instead of working on the old
system for those six months we work in
the new system so we're not adding new
functionality over this period so this
little section here that we would have
added a little bit of value to our users
no longer exists that disappears and
instead we start working on the rewrite
of our system
and at the start of our system in the
rewrite it's really quick to add
features probably even quicker than when
the first system started because now
we've got better ideas we've been
thinking about how we would improve it
for a few months before we did the
rewrite we know more about the business
domain things are looking great here
but it's not going to take six months
how do I know it's not going to take six
months well that's because I'm a
developer and developers are really
really bad at estimating
in fact instead of doing coding
assessments if you try and hire someone
they should do estimation assessments
and anyone who's really bad at
estimating must be an amazing developer
if anyone is really good at developing
is probably developing really good at
estimating it's probably a project
manager and shouldn't be developing
I myself and the world's okay is the
estimator
but even if you could estimate correctly
you're still not going to take six
months even if you your estimation for
what you think the system is it's going
to take six months is 100 accurate it's
still not going to be correct
because developers are also a bit like
that dog from up where you get
distracted by a squirrel
and you run off the systems that we work
on it's very very unlikely that any
large system that we work on will be 100
documented even if it is there's even
less chance that we'll have all of that
knowledge sitting in our head while
we're trying to thumb suck an estimate
it's going to be very difficult to be
able to get those guesses right
so we carry on working we do our rewrite
six months comes and goes and it's now
nine months and business comes to us and
says listen
we we can't go on like this we we need
new features we've got a compliance
deadline we have to meet gdpr 2.0 or
something
the return
um
so you start panicking and your team
starts working weekends working nights
you order pizzas every evening for the
team you've got a masseuse coming in to
to massage the team to relieve stress
and tension and you're you're just
driving a role into the ground
and eventually you're still not going to
be done and business is going to come to
you at a point and say
we can't do this
we you've got to cut this rewrite and
you panic a bit you panic because now
you've put a lot of effort into the new
system you love it you're emotionally
attached to this new design that you've
got so you compromise and you say Okay
business I'll tell you what got an idea
we've still got the old system that's
running in production right so we'll
have that and then we'll also deploy the
parts of the functionality that we've
currently written or that we've
Rewritten and then the users can use the
new system for the stuff we've Rewritten
and then for the ones we haven't done
yet they can use the old system right
but now we need to keep them up to date
so okay no problem we'll put an
integration layer between the two and
and then then everything will be fine
except we know that the integration
layer is going to suck because the
original system sucked
and the longer that this integration
layer sits in production that we have to
maintain and fix the more chance there
is of some of the bad elements from the
old system bleeding over into the new
system because it is going to be time
pressure you're going to say oh I need
to get this field into a report I'm I'm
just going to copy it in in the same way
that it is in the whole system
it happens
but anyway we're going to do this so
we're going to have three systems that
we have to maintain but at least now we
can add new functionality for our users
so we can meet those compliance
deadlines or whatever
once we've added that functionality we
can go back and carry on with the
migration right
I'm sure business will give us time then
they they will right please someone
they won't well they might give you a
little bit but you'll have to you'll
have to scramble for it and that
original system is going to live much
longer than you ever thought possible
it's a bit like trying to build an
airplane while you're flying it I asked
a stable diffusion to generate an image
of an airplane flying while you're
building it and I've got to say this is
also a really good description of
microservices it's
terrifying
so now that we after we've done our
distribute distribution of everything
the second thing that we can do to make
our system worse is to attempt to do a
big bang rewrite
I said there were two cases where Big
Bang rewrite works the first is if the
system is actually small enough to be
Rewritten in a reasonable time frame
this is tricky though because it
developers sucker estimating so how do
you know that it's small enough
maybe it is maybe it isn't
I don't know it's unlikely it's also you
kind of have to take into the effect in
into a consideration that working on an
old system that you want to rewrite is
is unpleasant it's emotional so it's
hard for you to be objective about how
long it will take to actually do a
rewrite
so the first time it works is if the
system is small
the second time that all that it will
work is for your CV
so you start the rewrite and you do the
rewrite in the most amazing technology
possible and then a month after you've
started working on it you go for
interviews
um and leave
it works for you not for the project
but that's fine
so this is what we've got now we've got
three systems we're maintaining and the
longer that these systems are in
production the longer the more of the
suckiness we've got from the first
system bleeding over into our new system
as well
let's make it worse
we don't want to be malicious about it
though so remember this situation where
we had the dropper from performance
because Long Live calls waiting for
responses we don't want to do that in
the new system right we we want to
accidentally make bad systems not
purposefully make them
so instead of service a call in the
credit card service because it's going
to wait around for response and the same
problem is going to happen what we'll do
is we'll introduce a queue and then
server say you can put a message on the
Queue to say charge this person's credit
card and once that message is on the
Queue service a can end its call and
terminate and then we're done right
that means that service a is less likely
to live long enough to get promoted to
Gen 2 so we've solved that problem and
everything's fine
we then go to our credit card service
which takes a message of the queue call
Swift or whatever payment provider we
want to use and everything's fine
okay cool cool except now our message
gets the front of the queue and this
message says charge Williams credit card
50 pounds
cool as we do that call though something
goes wrong the network fails somewhere
along the line uh Swift fails for
whatever reason something happens
okay but we haven't actually charged
William's credit card yet but that's
fine the message is gone
well that's no good we've lost money for
our customers right that's a financial
operation that we don't want to lose for
them
so we certainly think okay um what we'll
do is
when we take the message off the queue
we'll we'll process it in a loop and in
that Loop we'll put a try catch so if
something goes wrong we'll just keep
processing it and that'll be fine
and then we call Swift and then
something goes wrong and maybe
something's wrong on Swift side and they
have to reboot some servers internally
whatever it is and they come to us and
say you you're ddosing those guys
uh whenever something goes wrong you're
just calling us non-stop you need to
back off
so you go back and you introduce some
sort of timer mechanism and you say well
okay this message each message can only
be processed five times every minute yes
perfect and then that goes into
production and and Swift is at least
happy with you there
but then you get someone like William
who puts his credit card details in
incorrectly on purpose because he
doesn't want to pay 50 pounds
and then the message will never actually
get processed because that's an invalid
credit card number
or maybe there's a bug in the code
Upstream that generated that message and
that failed but now that message is
sitting at the front of the queue and
everything behind it isn't getting
processed and you're like well
okay I know what we'll do we'll
introduce a dead letter q and then we'll
take that message move it to the Daily
queue oh don't worry we'll also make
software to manage the data queue and
this is a really cool bit of
architectural kit this is fun to work
with and you're you're living for this
this framework that you're making but it
is a framework that you're making
and in this case this type of problem is
solved by poly and service Transit Rebus
come on there's there's many options in
the.net space that will handle this
problem for you
so but instead of doing that you're
getting a lot of joy out of working on
this framework you might even open
source it one day
that moment when you get your first star
and your open source GitHub project it's
oh
so the next technique we're going to use
is we're going to make sure that we
suffer heavily from not invented here
syndrome and every framework that we
come across we say no we don't want to
use that because it doesn't 100 percent
meet our requirements we're going to
make our own one and that's how we ended
up with so many JavaScript front-end
Frameworks a few years ago
but we're going to keep doing this
because honestly when you've got a
system like this some of the only joy
you can get is working on cool
engineering problems and you're not
going to get that from business problems
usually so we've got our monolith we've
got our new system that we're busy
maintaining we've got our integration
layer between the two and then we've got
this really cool framework that we're
working on at least one try for many
I highly recommend it
and at this point we're basically not
delivering any business functionality at
all anyway it's we're having a lot of
fun on our custom stuff but not really
doing much for the business
so they're going to come to us and say
listen we we need the search screen that
you've been promising us for months
please can you give us a search screen
and you think
fine
we'll do it we've got a product service
and maybe they're an e-commerce site
they're uh they're Amazon no
rainforest.com so they're rainforest.com
and you can search for product or that
you can purchase project Products off of
rainforest.com and you've designed your
product service to meet to match this
requirement so you've got for instance
the name of a product you've got the
price of the product there's images for
it whether it's in stock somewhere
description uh the rating of the product
you know fairly standard producty things
we've all seen these types of things
before and you come up with a class and
a data structure that sort of represents
this which looks a bit like this all
those fields except it's got an ID yay
computer science
and based off of this you can go and
implement the customer's search screen
that they wanted so you can in your
product service have a little search API
pass in a text string and we'll we'll
search the name in the description and
split back all of the products that
match
and you pat yourself on the back and you
go back to work on your framework now
the business is satisfied
but then they come to you and they say
I've got an idea
the correct response when business comes
to you and says I've got an idea is for
you to excuse yourself in the room say
you want to get a coffee or something
quickly leave the building get in your
car and go home and pretend it never
happened
but you don't do that
so business says I've got an idea we
have a theory that especially on
consumable items if someone has ordered
a product before there's a higher
likelihood that they'll order the same
product again
so can we maybe have a little field that
shows hey you've ordered this before
on the search screen
and you you pause what you're doing on
your cool framework and you you swing
over in your chair and you you kind of
just look incredulously at this person
has asked you the most obscene question
ever because the order status is not in
the product service that's in the order
service that's a very different thing
but you you want to get back to working
on the cool stuff as quickly as possible
so you make them promise that this is
the only time they're going to do this
even pinky promise with him
and they agree that pinky promise and
and promised to name their firstborn
child after you as well
so you said okay fine so the product
service once we get the request we'll
also then call off into the order
service just this once and and we'll go
back to doing the cool stuff again
I mean this isn't this isn't pretty
you've made your search screen slow
because now your product screen product
service has to First query its database
then query another service then put all
the stuff together
but it's just once it's fine right then
business comes to you and says hey I've
got an idea
remember the correct response
leave the room leave the boat and get in
your car go home and denial denial
denial
we want to reward our gold customers and
give them a 10 discount so special
pricing per customer please
and I mean at this point you may as well
give up because they're going to come
and ask for every single service in your
system anyway so the customer status
doesn't sit in the order service it
doesn't sit in the product service it
sits in the customer service so we're
just going to start chaining all of
these calls together and eventually
we're going to end up with dedicated
teams that can manage our API gateways
has anybody worked with in an
environment where there's a dedicated
data Power Team and only they can make
changes to your API Gateway
it happens
these API gateways can solve these
problems for you but they can become
another not can they are another layer
of coupling that you introducing into
your system a new sort of Technology you
have to worry about has anyone seen this
video
if you haven't do it it's called
microservices on YouTube by a channel
called crisam it is the best description
of this type of thing ever the the man's
face it's like a mirror image of me in
business meeting sometimes
why did we end up like this though I
mean we've got a product service it's
nice it's concrete it's very neatly
encapsulated we've got an order service
a customer service look at these classes
these are beautiful
why is this not working for us
and the reason is that people don't
interact with products on your servers
they don't they don't productize things
they don't product key
they search for things
they perform operations in your system
they don't perform things even if you're
even if your your user is busy updating
your product catalog they're still not
producting they are updating a product
in your catalog
and having having the idea that a
product service a thing service is going
to neatly encapsulate and not bleed over
into other boundaries is a bit weird
it's like when you do a search on a
screen
it's like a puzzle that you're building
you take pieces from different places
and you put them together to make the
whole puzzle
although I've actually just realized the
person is a really bad metaphor for this
because it's always got the same pieces
in the same places
but think of something like that right
you you you're taking information from
different places and you you're putting
it together in to build one experience
for someone
the thing is people interact with your
system by doing things not by objecting
so the next technique that we can use is
when we Define our service boundaries we
can make sure that they are designed
based off of nouns and not verbs
anybody working in insurance this is a
big one that I see very often in
Insurance space you don't have to put
your hand up if if you are doing this
but if you've got a claimed service or
policy service you know usually usually
that's a bit of a red flag and something
to look at people well I suppose claims
might work sometimes because you do
submit a claim but people don't policy
they they do a quotation they go through
the order process
their underwriting is a process their
own policy
Okay so we've got our three systems our
monolith our integration layer our new
system we've got a cool framework that
we're working on ezel and we've made
sure that when we defined our service
boundaries they're all based on nouns so
that we can maximize the chance of
having cross-communication service calls
between everything building another
great monolith on that side
let's see if we can make this even worse
by trying to make it better right so
we'll go back to that search screen
well we don't want this right this is
bad let's see if we can improve it what
we'll do is we'll introduce a new
service a search service to search as a
verb we're doing something right yay
we're learning
the search service will be a dedicated
service only responsible for searching
so it won't have a product class it will
have a search product class which has a
couple new fields on it and if we if we
need to change the business rules in the
search Cloud search service we can
update that right
sounds reasonable how do we get the data
into the search service well that's easy
we'll Pub sub it right
so what we'll do is we'll table tell the
product service Hey whenever you update
your product list publish an event for
us please and then I'll maintain a
search catalog and I'll update that
whenever the product has changes
okay and whenever the customer status
changes also publish an event and then
the search service can update its list
and we can do the same for the order
service
this is an awful lot of data duplication
we've got things in different places but
we're smart we're Engineers we can
explain this away right the source of
truth if you use that phrase that's
clever the source of truth of the
products is in the product service right
what we've got in the search service is
a it's a different model it's a what can
we call it a read model that's right
we're doing a projection this is cqrs
yay and we're using we're using Pub sub
right so there's events so it's a cqrs
and event sourcing and and services
Services domains domains we're doing
dddcqrs event sourcing this is a good
system design
Go technology
we still have the same coupling problems
here if the customer service changes the
way that it rewards customers that has
to flow through into the search Service
as well for instance if the customer
service says instead of rewarding
discounts based on status we want to
reward the top 100 customers our
100 customers will get 50 off
the next 200 get 10 and then the rest
just get an extra 10 added on because we
want to help them monetize their way up
into the into the stream right
we make that change in the customer
service we then have to make that same
change in the search service because now
the search service doesn't have statuses
that we have to worry about that
coupling still exists we haven't hidden
it away
and the the thing to remember here is
that even though this is
it looks like it's separate and it looks
like it's decoupled
the The View isn't the same so The
Logical boundaries and the deployment
boundaries the physical boundaries are
different and we've cheated at the as if
they're the same if we have a search
service and it's deployed separately it
must be separate from everything else
right it must be decoupled
but it's not I've always really liked
this poster for episode one with Anakin
standing there and he showed up rejected
as Darth Vader I've always thought this
was incredibly clever
because we know Anakin is Darth Vader
who is going to become Darth Vader but
in this particular instance In This
Moment he is not
The Logical Darth Vader is different
from the physical Anakin at this point
in time
so what I'm going to do now is I'm going
to show you a technique that can make
this previous situation a little bit
better I don't want you to go and apply
this because you don't want to make
things better
uh
also because it's not a golden Hammer it
doesn't work in every scenario so don't
just go and say William said apply this
it sometimes makes things better
sometimes it's not applicable but it is
a technique you can use to get rid of
the distributed uh replication of data
that you're going to build
so what we'll do is we'll replace our
search service with a search engine
right that sounds that sounds more
natural doesn't it search engine search
service search engine
and what we're going to do is we're
going to implement what's known as the
engine pattern
so the engine pattern has some coupling
in it but not logical not business
coupling what I mean by that so the
search engine will expose a contract
that the other services must comply to
so they'll expose for instance three
interfaces maybe and I find product
interface which given a text string will
filter through a list of products and
return them
we'll also have an interface for eye
price products so for a particular user
and a particular product what discount
percentage should they get
and we'll have a third interface for
itrack orders which just tells you
returns true or false whether someone
has ordered a product previously or not
the search engine takes these three
interfaces compiles them into a dll and
hosts it on the internal nougat feed or
something like that
the product servers the customer service
and the order service can then download
that nougat package and Implement
whatever interfaces they want so what I
mean by that is that the product service
can implement the product finder class
and the product finder class knows how
to query the product service database I
hope it's clear that the product finder
Clause sits squarely within the logical
boundary of the product service
the customer service can do the same
with a status pricer and then the order
service can do the same with a order
history class so all of these in classes
implement the interface that was exposed
by the search engine
and they're currently sitting within the
service boundaries that they're
implemented in and this is great
how do we wire this up together though
so what we can do is we can take the
product finder class
compile it into its own assembly
and then take that assembly and stick it
in the app folder of the search engine
and then when the search engine runs and
it needs to do a search it can ask.net
hey.net give me all of the classes that
Implement I find products and don't know
will go oh he has one it's the product
finder class there you go
the search engine can invoke that
product finder class which will then go
from query the product database because
it knows how to talk to its own database
and then we can do the same from the
customer service you can take the
customer status pricer and compile that
into a dll
copy paste their dll into the search
engine folder and then the search engine
can apply that to the products that it's
got from the search result
and we can do the same with the order
history one we can track what the person
is ordered before
how is this different from the previous
one we're still doing three sets of
queries right
well if this if the customer service
changes the way that it does discounts
and it goes away from status and and
changes over to ranking
the customer service deletes that status
pricer and creates a new class A ranking
pricer compiles that ranking pricer into
a DLo and paste the dll into the search
engine folder now the search engine when
it does a query and it tries to find all
of the prices the high price product
instances it doesn't have the status
price anymore it now gets the ranking
pricer
the changes were constrained logically
with Indie customer service physically
though we deployed a different assembly
into a different runtime but that's not
really a big problem
the interesting thing with this type of
pattern is that
you can apply uh you can apply things
that seem like they come outside of that
domain into different domains so for
instance the product service could
Implement a daily pricer maybe every
Monday these products get a 50 discount
that can get put directly alongside the
existing pricer
the same with the order service it can
create its own bulk history
pricer where if a customer over the
lifetime or the customer's account has
ordered 99 of these items on the 100th
item they get a 99 discount
that can also just be deployed alongside
and all of that sits and resides
logically within those individual
service boundaries physically we've
deployed it somewhere else but logically
it's separate
I always find it interesting that when
people consider this type of idea
that it kind of it feels weird to them
like we're putting these things together
we're coupling it right
but this type of distinction between
logical and physical is fine when you're
talking about scaling out instances
we'll take the same code and run it in
two places that's also physical
differences but the logical logically
it's still the same thing
so don't do this in fact what you need
to do is you need to make sure that you
conflate your logical and your physical
boundaries for everything that you do in
your system
so a quick recap what we've done is
we've put an HTTP calling in front of
everything
we made sure to attempt a big bang
rewrite note I didn't say do I did they
I shouldn't do that oops
we didn't use any official Frameworks we
created a whole bunch of cool Frameworks
that that we get joy out of we then also
made sure that we use nouns instead of
verbs when defining our service
boundaries so that we can get the
maximum chance of having cross-service
communication and in the places where we
have cross-service communication we made
sure that we made we kept the logical
and the deployment boundaries the same
throughout the entire system
and if you follow these five techniques
you'll have a great time looking for a
new job somewhere I'm sure
I did say I would get you out of here a
little bit early and I'm pleased to say
that I did that if you have any
questions you can ask them now otherwise
you can also find me around NDC I'll be
here tomorrow and maybe a little bit
later I'm always excited to talk about
right and bad systems so if that's a if
that's a common interest we can we can
write bad code together
any questions
no okay great thank you everyone
[Applause]